in this capsule we will see how we
can calculate different probability to
from a psn network we saw that a
Bezian network that corresponds to a
all of us c there are
organized in a graph a serious one that
is oriented in this case the arcs of
my perfect graph but determine the
properties of the probability tables
conditional between these different
variables and the probabilities of the tables
conditional are specified in
inside the Béziers network no it's
another part the information that
was giving the inside of network b if we
continue we have hours when the
knots and it's a law and bows
inputs does not allow to determine the
size of the probabilities of the tables of
conditional policy then the value
of these probabilities is also
something that must be specified in
a network bezily start with the calculation
of politics can be the most fun
are the joint probabilities
so in fact a bezier network this is a
compact way of representing these
joint policies there it is a way
more compact to represent them than under
the shape of a table where we at the last
column fits enjoy and each
row corresponds to different
joint policies for all
possible configurations of our variables
random
we have seen that by definition a small
recall the joint producti of two
random variables x1 x2 thin and the
probability so his blue fingers
take different mistakes at the same
time we also saw that the pole tes
conditional x hours knowing ex-dl
that we note or leave so from
to shelter conditional ex by knowing
x2 but it's not possible to rewrite
joint probity etc. 110.2 as
being the product of parity
the first variable sacha the second
times the probability of marginal the
second variable
we could also have written that as
stamps and 2 x 2 knowing ex 1 xp 2 x 1
so we can do it in both directions
so in general we know that the
joint probabilities can only be
decomposed as local probabilities
marginal condition between
barriers to the web in a network
beziers what are we going to see specifically
know that the marginal probability in
all the variables in my network
beziers this is going to be the product of
conditional probabilities precisely
and the conditional probabilities that
will be the one determined by or defined
by my conditional quality tables
so that's going to be the priorities of each
exquisite random variables being
given the parents of my variable
random xxi no i'm going to do the
product everything is not useful it's going me
give the joint probability for
everything but variable to you now we
will make the parallel between the rule of
chaining we saw previously for
for the probabilities
we have seen that the joint probability of
a random variable it can always
written as being the product of
priorities of each of the variables
random and xi knowing all the
previous random variables
so I defined a variable order
random then there i can set the
joint joint probability on any
but random variable as being the
produces conditional policies of
each variable its dear the one that
precedes in my order now
make the parallel with their calculations
joint network policy
beziers we have that joint probability
this is again the product the
conditional output product but
when if it's political, it's
6 pm in just the parents so
firstly we only have this
exactly the same formula as this here if
by a deck ci corresponds to all
previous random variables
so if I replace with xi by g
exactly the same formula and we can
so in fact conclude that in a network
beziers we have that these policies
conditional there can be written under
this form there whatever the
parents as defined in my serious
and so that means in fact that knowing
my parents the eksi policy does not
depends more on other variables that
do not belong to xxi's parents
and our ways of thinking that in fact my
bezier network will finally define me
implicitly independence
conditional so eksi labs
is independent of all others
random variables that do not belong
not to parents
given these parents there and so
using the structure of the Bézian network
I have implicitly different
of conditional independence which are
defined let's do the example of the calculation of
joint policy
so I have the formula here for a network
bezers parents of the calculation of
joint probabilities
now that I'm going to calculate the
joint probability on your in my
example i call marie call alarm
burglaries and earthquake and probity
specifically the case where I will sign
respectively these random variables
the aaf would dream fresh fake fake according to the
formula is the probability of
people call sasha are parents who at
both the quality of marries her song
parents who also alarm the probability
of his alarm chased by a burglary
and earthquake for the pole your two
burglaries sacha his parents in this
case if there is not so it's the politi
a priori of burglaries times the
a priori earthquake policy
now I consult my tables of
take advantage to replace all these
probabilities their share their value so
if you do the exercise of seeing them
that these ninety percent
seventy for that point a reason to
99.9 for that and 98.8 for that so we
notice that these two last here in
did I got them
because this figure c1 - parity
to be assigned Le Havre who 0.001
right here check the grading I get
points 99 8 by doing 1 - 0 points 0 0 2
so I make the product of all this and then
it gives me that seems to me get the
calculation of my joint probity on everything
but random variable for a
specific assignment of these variables
random
ok now let's move on to calculating
marginal probabilities so a reminder the
marginal policies it's policies
welcomed on a subset of but
random variable
for example I could be interested in
the marginal policy that there is no
burglaries but that the blade sounds
so in this case I should summit
about the possible values ​​of others
random commodities that are not observed
so who passed or 1 to know the
political deserves it
the proof by which the value is yours
marie calls the random variable
earthquake is the random variable I had
so I'm napping on all
sgm values ​​possible from these others
random variables are for observing
so marked in that if I have a
more complicated than we saw
to spare a triple jump I have a
sum on variables mjs
so m are on mcm will take value
true or false j will take their bike must
s going to take the busy at the bottom so I
do twice twice 2 so eight
themes in this summation here ok so
first thing that we take my
joint probability here then I'm going
convert it to there
with the joint priority setting
in a Bezier network we produced
probabilities extracted from the tam de
probity conditioned so that gives me pdj
to get rid of purchases at the purchase price c and
2 c is s follows a trick I want
to do is I'm going to change the order
half summons because I had a
summation on m
apart from the actually I had a
safe solution followed by interventions
on j followed by training on m
and therefore a property of the summations and
lighter like that is that I can
change their orders without changing the
result among other things the summit on
a first mast that after that but arises
finally summit would be this so
and we will see later the shark
advantage of doing that so it's all
that I changed otherwise I just changed
the order of summations
now we notice that in this
product of five values ​​here here there are some
a single hell of these factors that
depends on the variable m
actually I got m here but otherwise
in the term waters I have no m
and because of the property of
distributive it and therefore product by
example if I have twice 3 + 2 x 4
the judgment of ten of the victims tell me that
it's also equal to 2 x 3 + 4 so I
can invoke this rule to make it
take out all the terms here the factors
which does not depend on m in front of the sum m
or in another way I can introduce
the sum
m for all purposes then put here only
terms that depend on m
so that's what I did to this
language if I took my tempo 2nd sacha
on an equal v can I go right push
the order of
evidence of the factors in my
product is not important i can them
changed so I can put it to the whole
end and there I can push the sum on m
up to knowing p2m and then put
before all the other terms that was
constant with respect to the variable m
so it's just an application of the
distributive rule love you applied
on a number of term inhabitants in
a sum ok so because all this does not
does not depend on m I can put them in
before and I can x the sum on m
only terms that depend on m
now we notice that this sum
there here on m6 a sum on a single
Probability distribution policy
that they conditional and since I'm doing
the sum on m
which is the theme on which we evaluate
probabilities this sum the customs
I do not care
because it's probabilities so I
will have a liver several terms here
so I can just bar this
part of my equation
now I continue to do that so
I notice here that I have only one term
who's leaving to all the others here
do not depend on j so i can them
push ahead of the sum pops up so
pushed right
mason popped up again this is a
man arises from the probity of knowing me
to the sums due by haiti must is
equals stationery so I prepared this
part of my product there is nothing left
just these terms here here now we
note houses a sum on sc the age is
more than a term that starts from
I have this term here and then this term
here then unfortunately it turns out
in the conditioning part you so I
could not do the trick
I get a sum who who are 1
I could still take this term
does not conceal sent forward but for
to make it simpler I will spend everything from
following an explicit form on the sum
on it ie I'm going
take my three terms here and then I
will replace s by its first value
which is true anymore
again these three terms here
but where is it going to be assigned to must
now I replace all of his
tesla products by their values
associated in my tables of
probabilities so here here here is the
three terms of policies that I have
need and I'm going to product then that's me
give my answer
so that gives me my calculation of
marginal probabilities then we saw
that the marginal probability for
burglary and to the soul that normally
if we use the laterites base
priorities should require a sum
on mjs it could be reduced for
to get a form where we had a sum
only on is so only on the
random variable earthquake I made a
mathematical proof of that but actually
we have a rule that we can
invoke that just allows observing
the graphical structure between the nodes
in winter moratorium to eliminate the clashes
who have not be involved in the calculation
this rule said that it is possible
we can ignore the clouds
calculation of probabilities marginal can
ignore leonard and descendants forgive
dummies whose descendants are only
not to observe us then in our
example we managed one and I call
and marries call and if we apply the
rule but actually we observed
that I call a town hall called they
do not have in their descendants
burglaries and burglaries and
the soul is the two variables that are
observed for which one evaluates
probabilities
so actually part of people
call I can not follow arches in
done there is no art clokey them
descendants I can not follow art that
would allow me to get to burglary
or
alarmed variable observed in reverse in
the earthquake case
six years as direct descendants alarm
which is one of the variables observe and at
because of that we can not simply
ignore it when calculating
marginal probabilities when it wants
to say that in fact we can look at
our network beziers then if we have a
marginal policy has calculated on
random variables observed but what
I can do it's just ignored
the nine that matches that they
respect this rule to those whose
descendants are not names
observed then do my pole calculations
marginal only from the
other variables so only the
other cables that are either
variables observe or variables that
I failed to eliminate and finally
as regards the calculation of
conditional probabilities
since khalid clips are
conditional it's just a ratio
between marginal or
joint so to enjoy an event
knowing of events b it's always
the parity of a and b so the event has
and b at the same time divided by parity
marginal of the event b so
and since we are able to
calculate marginal pro liter or
conjunctions in a Bézian network but I
am able to calculate all
conditional policies possible that
could interest me
I can get the formula to do
this calculation does not know what we are going to sell
the following capsules is that the
benefits of the Bezier networks still a
times it's going to be from its structure
in serious it's going to be possible
to identify independence
conditional ie to identify
variables that I can eliminate
my calculation of policies
conditional because they are
conditioning is dependent on the
variable for which I calculate a
conditioned priority to see
different rules to facilitate this
kind of calculation there and identify
functional independence in the
next capsules and that's fine
actually allow to reduce the calculations
to do for the calculation of these
conditional probabilities